they had been waiting for the rains
dreading them for months monsoon season
has finally come to the refugee camps
outside Cox's Bazar in Bangladesh for
their a hinge of people who fled what
the UN calls ethnic cleansing in Myanmar
this is fresh peril and time is running
out to make things safe landslides are
the immediate danger at least 12 people
have died so far among the first was a
jido Begum she was 6 years old and this
was her home this is the only picture
her father Roux Holliman has of her the
identity card issued to every refugee
when they arrived last month Agito left
home with friends to go and collect
firewood she was crushed to death when
the earth above her gave way it's the
first time the family has talked about
her death two foreign journalists there
nearly 1 million people in the camp it's
the biggest in the world more like a
city than temporary shelter and nearly
200,000 people are at risk of landslides
and flood refugees themselves directed
by international aid agencies are
working nonstop to put up defenses
against the torrential downpour that
they live in very flimsy shelter to
begin with you know that's very much at
the forefront of our attentions and the
fact that it is a race against time and
that we need to move people to safe
locations as fast as we can and make
sure that they have the food and the
resources and the relief that they need
to survive
those relocation efforts are under way
in this operation 158 people were being
moved from Hills to lands that have been
bulldozed flat over the last few months
we followed one family on the farm
[Music]
Muhammad told us that when he came here
with his wife his three daughters and
his grandson he built their shelter
himself it was destroyed by heavy rains
but he didn't know what to expect at the
new site
this is Muhammad's new home bigger and
better prefabricated shelters are ready
here
each allocated to a family he told us
that away from the hills he now feels
safe the rain comes so suddenly then
with such power
it's hard to predict where and who is at
risk the rain is coming down really
really hot now this happens several
times a day and when the revenger fled
mine mar their villages were burned they
escaped those flames but it's this water
that now brings a lethal threat the
refugees we spoke to want to go home but
they know it's still far from safe in my
MA they're here for the long haul
first they they have to make it through
the rain Tom cheshire at Sky News in the
coup to prolong refugee camp Bangladesh